people who you hate who've had success
if you refuse to learn from them you've
boxed yourself in if you only learn from
people who look exactly like you or
doing exactly what you're doing you're
losing all of that stuff is the best
right all of the early failures I'm so
proud of the videos that I put out
however many years ago you go back watch
my channel I'm super boring I'm on I
have a suit and a tie on I'm sitting
down I'm trying to memorize a script and
so I'm always like looking up in to the
left a little bit to trying to like
remember what did I say it's super
awkward people still go back and and
like the content was decent but the
delivery was terrible like its
cringe-worthy to watch but it also shows
the journey right I don't want to just
come out of the gate and be perfect and
part of part of being a great thought
leader is sharing the vulnerabilities
sharing what your weaknesses are sharing
if you're nervous are sharing nobody
wants to learn from somebody was perfect
they want to learn from somebody who is
like them who is either on the journey
to figure it out or has figured
something out
so if you're on the journey to find
something you haven't found it yet don't
pretend like you found it because then
you won't connect with people but just
you taking the step and going on a
journey is inspiring because a lot of
people want to take the journey but
they're too afraid so saying you go
often do something will inspire them to
do something in their life as well so I
see really kind of want all of you to
make a video that really sucks and post
it just to have the recall in three
years to look back like holy cow look
would I look at that in Toronto that's
the best but but I'm I'm a weird kind of
masochist or something like I like I
like I like the suck like I like I like
the pain in the struggle
I think it's the best like if there's
something that is challenging or
difficult or judgment that I have to run
towards it and I think that's how you
end up growing I would be proud of a
post like that's that's a game I tell
myself I'm proud of a terrible post
right Tony and I were talked in the car
on the way back yesterday and I
challenged him to do a freestyle rap in
a way that hadn't done it before and I
called him out on Instagram stories to
just to like double make sure that it
happened and and I told like even if
even if it's a total fail even if like
you have to post something post if it's
garbage posted something you need to
build the momentum you need to feel what
it's like like press post and if you're
super anxious and nervous and afraid of
judgment like then you have to do it if
you're afraid of judgment they have to
go up and do that thing just to release
the fear of judgment my we had a dance
team that won a local competition and so
we took them out to a nail salon as a
celebration and Alex and I went along
because he was you were in it right you
were in the group he was in the
performance group and I was just going
to support and then one of the one of
the ladies a joke that's like hey are
you guys gonna get your nails done too
and the initial the initial replies no
I'm not get my nails done but the only
acceptable answer is that's not an
expression of me that's not how I
express myself but I caught a little
moment of I could get my nails done
because I have meetings and I have
YouTube videos to make and I'm speaking
at an event and I'm gonna have my nails
painted that's ridiculous and because I
was afraid of that judgment then I had
to go and do it just to release it just
to feel it just to walk around with my
nails painted just because right because
like you guys don't own me right nobody
out there owns me and so if you're
feeling that's the way like I tricked
myself if I ever feel that I'm playing
small because of somebody else's opinion
then I have to go and do that thing even
if I didn't want to do the thing
because releasing the fear of judgment
serves me so we got our nails painted
Alex went blue and then had to go teach
that night or the next day at class and
I went orange with racing stripes and I
felt I felt awkward for the first day
but also just feeling feeling the
feeling the judgement rights like going
to pick up a package for my concierge
and wanting to hide my nails like no I'm
not hiding my nails I'm gonna show it
off
proudly just because just because like I
will eat the judgment all day long
because it makes me stronger
brahim has a great story we're into
Walmart and he was flying a hair dryer
hair dryer a blow dryer for his hair and
he d-ends me to tell me the story will
you tell the story
[Music]
so I caught myself for the first time
being scared of judgments but this pink
hair dryer walking around look at me in
my pink hair dryer right and the point
isn't a show-off or getting in anybody's
face it's just to not be afraid of the
judgment and I think we play small by
default I think by default we just go in
and play small because of other people's
judgments and so it's when you can catch
it then you have to go up and do
something like bruh he might have walked
into Walmart and added to his collection
of pink hair dryers and just like walk
out normally by default but when you can
catch it that's when you have to do
something about it
so where this really sunk in for me was
when I was walking down I was walking on
the street coming to walk near TDS and I
was listening to music and I had my
headphones on and I'm bouncing you know
I got my music on and I live I live
close to here like a 15 minute walk away
and as I get too young and Shepard the
major intersection there there's tons of
people so I owe those people yeah go
small right and then I caught it
like why am i dancing smaller who cares
because of because I add one you know
well I mean like who cares there's a
bunch of strangers and so because of
that then I had I had to make it even
bigger I'm dancing there on the street
corner not to get into anybody's face
not to show them up not to not to say
hey look at me but just to release the
judgement and the thing I think of is
how many times have I walked to that
street corner and then the exact same
thing just never caught it like hundreds
of times I probably done that dancing
down the street being super happy and
then get to the street corner and then
just by default just by default and so
because I caught it then I had to go off
and change it even though dancing giant
on a street corner is not an expression
of myself because I was nervous of
people's judgments and I had to go up
into that thing and so the more that you
can catch those things and then do the
thing that you're afraid of that's when
you start to shift your identity when
you catch it and you don't do it that
actually makes it worse if you catch
yourself if brahim caught himself in the
walmart with the pink thing crouched
over and he didn't go off and then like
continued and he had the awareness that
makes it worse then you reinforce a
negative behavior then you're teaching
yourself that I'm the kind of person who
when I'm faced with judging a criticism
I play small or even the fear of
judgment of criticism I play small so
super important because if you can catch
it first step is just awareness because
most of the time you won't even catch it
I've probably played small a hundred
times already today without even
noticing it but when you catch it what
do you do if you jump into the
discomfort then you start to set that
new identity for yourself if you don't
do it and you shy away then you're
creating a negative pattern that becomes
really difficult to break out of so
that's why I love jumping into the pain
of the judgment of the frustration
because I know something greats coming
okay but like any time you feel afraid
then you have to do that thing just just
to just to release the fear that
especially with a judgement you know if
you're afraid of diving onto a metal
spike okay like be afraid of that you
don't have to go off and do it but like
fear of judgment is the thing that you
need to destroy especially if you want
to be a thought leader because you will
get judged and not all your messages
will resonate with people and that's
okay like you can't you can't let the
fear of one person's and they get a
feedback prevent you from getting
started you get negative feedback one it
could just be a straight-out hater
somebody just their hater their negative
and and I just have empathy for them I
think your hater makes you greater and I
think I just have empathy for them and
the best part of the day is coming to
your Instagram post or your YouTube
video and leaving a negative comment
like how crappy does their life have to
be for that to be the highlight of their
day pretty bad and so I feel sorry for
them I then also try to look is there
anything in this that I can learn from
because I think being able to learn from
different styles makes you better if you
can only take feedback when it's
sugar-coated and really nicely wrapped
like hey I really loved your video and
it's great that you're out doing this
but I had a little tiny you know a
little suggestion like maybe don't rock
so much in your chair when you're doing
your post right if that's the only way
you take feedback you're going to lose
so somebody's yelling in your face but
there may be a kernel of truth I don't
amazing thank you so I have I have
empathy for I understand that this this
person's life must be terrible that this
is the highlight and maybe there's a
kernel of truth in here that I can learn
from to make me
I love learning from people that I don't
like I think your goal is to learn from
anybody who can teach you so if you guys
have seen my office the wall I got Steve
Jobs up there Kanye West like a bunch of
people I don't want to be a father like
Steve Jobs but I want to learn how to be
a visionary like Steve Jobs so you can
learn something from one person whether
whether you're a chump fan or chump
hater or Obama fan Obama haters like you
should be able to learn from both of
them I look at someone like Trump who
you know what was his election promise I
want to build a wall okay I want to
build a wall great you don't have to
agree with the wall but I knew what he
wanted to do looking from the outside
looking for my Canada looking down at
the US like what what was happening the
campaign what did Hillary stand for I
don't know not Trump so Trump is great
at having a big idea and be able to talk
about it just use yours for positivity
don't yours don't make yours being I'm
gonna build a wall and shut people out
use yours for positivity people who you
hate who've had success if you refuse to
look to learn from them you box yourself
in if you only learn from people who
look exactly like you or doing exactly
what you're doing
you're losing Trump doesn't care if you
don't remember not but if you could pull
one thing because I think you can learn
from everybody as long as it's a
positive message everything is believed
right that's my one words what flows
through all the content I make there's
never a there's never a negativity
there's never there's never like yelling
that somebody's never telling somebody
that they're stupid if I did the ten
stupidest Kanye moments of all time I'm
sure that video would blow up but if I'm
doing Kanye I'm only showing the
positive side of Kanye that's the reason
why I started the top ten series was
because a friend of mine was dissing
Kanye and I'm like somebody's got to
stand up for Kanye and he was talking
about Taylor Swift in the in the Kanye
moment it was like seven years later
like why are you still talking about
this and I think it's easy to see Kanye
only for the negativity
and the the crazy stuff that he does but
there's also a lot of genius behind
there that people don't see you know
he's won more music awards and anybody
at his age look at someone like John
Legend you know John Legend John Legend
like he's he comes off as like the
nicest guy of all time his name is John
Stevens
he got named John Legend because he's
friends with Kanye there at a Chicago
bar and Kanye said or John's John Legend
said I have a really old-school voice I
got an old soul and Kanye said you
should call yourself the legend and
John's like I can't call myself a legend
that's crazy like no no you got to call
it you got the chin journey and call
yourself John Legend
that's believed right like believing in
the guy other would be John Stevens and
it seems weird that John Legend and
Kanye West to be friends they seem like
two totally different characters so I
made the top 10 video the very first one
on Kanye West just to show mark my
friend who made the post on Kanye he's
like even if you hate Kanye you can
learn a lot from him and if you're
unwilling to learn from kinda you've
just locked yourself in and so mark saw
the video and he commented on it and his
comment is actually the most like
plussed or thumbs up comment on that
video and then that that started the
Cascade of okay I want to profile more
people because I think you can learn
from anybody who's had success raise
your standard Apple at the core its core
value is that passion not one drop of my
self-worth depends on your it's
something surreal this interview is done
as a part of my Toronto workshop if you
want more details on the next one to
sign up check out the link right there
next to me continue to believe and I'll
see
you there